Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
The 2016 Rio Olympic Games is right around
the corner, so it is the perfect time to talk
a bit about how we can use science to predict
the results.
Before we start, I'd like to mention that
we won't be showcasing any predictions for
this year's Olympics, instead, we are going
to talk about a model that was used to predict
the results of previous Olympic Games events.
So, the following, very simple question arises:
can we predict the future?
The answer is very simple: no, we can't.
End of video, thanks for watching!
Well, jokes aside, we cannot predict the future
itself, but we can predict what is likely
to happen based on our experience of what
happened so far.
In mathematics, this is what we call extrapolation.
There is also a big difference between trying
to extrapolate the results of one athlete,
or the aggregated number of medals for many
athletes, usually an entire nation.
To bring up an example about traffic, if we
were to predict where one individual car is
heading, we would obviously fail most of the
time.
However, whichever city we live in, we know
exactly the hotspots where there are traffic
jams every single morning of the year.
We cannot accurately predict the behavior
of one individual, but if we increase the
size of the problem and predict for a group
of people, it suddenly gets easier.
Going back to the Olympics, will Usain Bolt
win the gold on the 100 meter sprint this
year?
Predicting the results of one athlete is usually
hopeless, and we bravely call such endeavors
to be mere speculation.
The guy whose results we're trying to predict
may not even show up this year - as many of
you have heard, many of the Russian athletes
have been banned from the Olympic Games.
Our model would sure as hell not be able to
predict this.
Or would it?
We'll see in a second, but hopefully it is
easy to see that macro-level predictions are
much more feasible than predicting on an individual
level.
In fact, to demonstrate how much of an understatement
it is to say feasible, hold onto your seatbelts,
because Daniel Johnson, a professor of microeconomics
at the Colorado College created a simple prediction
model, that, over the past 5 Olympic Games,
was able to achieve 94% agreement between
the predicted and actual medal counts per
nation.
What is even more amazing is that the model
doesn't even take into consideration the athletic
abilities of any of these contenders.
Wow!
Media articles report that his model uses
only 5 simple variables: a country's per-capita
income, population, political structure, climate,
and host-nation advantage.
Now first, I'd first like to mention that
GDP per capita means the Gross Domestic Product
of one person in a given country, therefore
it is independent of the population of the
country.
If we sit down and read the paper, which is
a great and very easy read and you should
definitely have a look, it's in the video
description box.
So, upon reading the paper, we realize there
are more variables that are subject to scrutiny:
for instance, a proximity factor, which encodes
the distance from the hosting nation.
Not only the hosting nation itself, but its
neighbors are also enjoying significant advantages
in the form of lower transportation costs
and being used to the climate of the venue.
Unfortunately I haven't found his predictions
for this year's Olympics, but based on the
simplicity of the model, it should be quite
easy to run the predictions provided that
the sufficient data is available.
The take home message is that usually the
bigger the group we're trying to predict results
for, the lesser the number of variables that
are enough to explain their behavior.
If we are talking about the Olympics, 5 or
6 variables are enough to faithfully predict
nationwide medal counts.
These are amazing results that are also a
nice testament to the power of mathematics.
I also really like how the citation count
of the paper gets a big bump every four years.
I wonder why?
If you are interested in how the Olympic Games
unfold, make sure to have a look at the Olympics
reddit, I found it to be second to none.
As always, the link is available in the description
box.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!